passport mandates
is too invasive
just goes against everything that we
have known as a
democratic people
[Music]
i understand the pandemic is a problem
however we're going to look around us
and see also what we're doing when we're
implementing all these these mandates
you know we cannot we cannot kill the
patient in the name of curing them we
cannot do that guys
so we're gonna stand free that's what
we're gonna do
[Music]
we have mandated a vaccine vaccination
for transportation sector for the
airline sector for marine sector for the
rail sector last fall and we've done it
successfully so now almost 99 of workers
in those sectors are fully vaccinated
that has reduced infection rate that is
reduce hospitalization that's reduced
absenteeism and that added resilience to
our supply chain
[Music]
the risk factors extend beyond the core
demonstrators to those that have already
indicated um online and in other forums
that they're prepared to engage directly
or indirectly with the events that will
transpire over the next several days
here and some of them have been very
clear in inciting hate
encouraging acts of violence and
criminality
[Music]
you